captain cool we're so cadmium is an
element which is quite similar to
mercury and the way that most people
have seen cadmium is that cadmium
sulfide has a very strong orange color
and it is therefore used for dyeing
things that yellow or orange if you look
around your house or your parents house
you may easily find cast iron pot which
has cooking pot which has nice orange
sides and orange lid and this is using
cadmium sulfide as a glaze so this is a
this is a sample which was generated or
which was used by some of our
researchers in the school of chemistry
many years ago and this is a sample of
cadmium metal now it's very interesting
because it's stored in this really quite
nice box which was perhaps a medication
that somebody bought but if we open it
it's also I believe used to color the
plastic pipe that using the streets for
gas pipes and so on it
I think is colored with the cadmium
compound now in both these applications
even though that cadmium is quite
poisonous that they're so strongly fixed
into the materials that it isn't a
threat to people and we can see that the
lumps of the metallic cadmium now I'm
not going to touch the cadmium because
we know about some of the issues of
toxicity but it's used very often in
batteries or it was traditionally used
in batteries and it's really important
that we dispose of our batteries in a
correct way